the uk government's website has been
giving error messages in which
seems to be a worldwide internet issue
this morning major retail and news
websites
were also among those down let's
cross straight now to our correspondent
charlotte lomas who's in the newsroom
things are we're led to believe
improving but but a number of websites
down this morning
that's true in the last few minutes i've
just been checking some of those big
websites and some
seem to be slowly coming back online but
as you mentioned there there seems to be
a
major global problem with some
one of the most popular and biggest
websites across the world we've had lots
of news and media websites
facing problems including the guardian
and the financial times
also as you mentioned the the government
website here
as well as some users saying that
they're struggling to access services on
amazon
and spotify as well but as i said trying
to
slowly um come back online uh now and it
seems that
the actual cause of this might be the
data
center provider fastly which could be at
the center
of this internet outage now this is a
content delivery
network or cdn which sits between a
website and users and allows
users to access the content they're
after more quickly such as videos
and streaming and it's also used by
those major companies
to try and make their websites more
secure
now fastly is a u.s company and has said
that they're now investigating the
issues
and trying to understand exactly what
happened
all right well keep us up to date if you
would for now charlotte thanks a lot